contango can be one of the more
difficult to comprehend ideas when we
talk about futures markets but it's
really because it's used in different
contexts all the times with slightly
different meanings depending on whether
you're talking about someone
participating in a futures market or
whether whether an academic is talking
about it but first let me give you the
proper definition so the proper
definition of contango it's actually a
theory
it's actually a theory and it really
can't be you can't it really can't be
observed and the and contango theory
says that people are willing to pay more
to buy a
some commodity in the future than the
actual expected price of that commodity
so when we talk about expected price
this is a very theoretical thing
if you were to go and survey everyone
participating in the futures market and
say what what price do you think silver
will be in eight months and if they all
you know you took your survey and they
all told you the 100 percent honest
answer you could get this theoretical
expected price and maybe that
theoretical expected price is 33 dollars
so this right here is the expected price
expected price of silver in the market
and you could see from this futures
curve right here that the eighth the the
delivery the
silver futures contract for delivery
let me expected for delivery eight
months from now is trading above that
it's trading above the expected price
and it's probably trading above the
expected price
because people don't want to people who
want to have silver in eight months they
don't want to buy it today and have to
go rent some space and store the silver
and have to insure the silver and worry
about someone maybe stealing the silver
they'd rather just pay for a premium in
order for it to have to have it be
delivered in the future so this is kind
of the the correct academic definition
of can contango theory the theory that
the the futures price on a future
delivery date is going to be higher than
what the market actually expects so
people to some degree are paying a
premium to have the to have the delivery
of the silver to have it delayed
now in practice you will hear people say
that a market is
incontango and usually what they're
talking about they're usually talking
about one of two things and it's and
they're related but usually if they're
if they're a little bit more correct
about it they're talking about the idea
that the futures
price is on over time going to converge
downward to the actual spot price so
what i've done here so this is the
futures curve so this is just the price
the delivery price of the different con
contracts going forward in time but this
is the delivery price the market
delivery price today right now this is
how things trend over time so in magenta
i have the spot price trending over time
right over there and then you can see
that you have the four month
the the contract that's for delivery in
four months today
its price is a little bit under 35
dollars but as you approach its actual
delivery date so now we're actually
moving forward in time it has to
converge to the spot price otherwise
people could make free money on that day
and so the delivery date eight months
out has to converge to the spot price
eventually and so what you see is is
because the because the spot price
hasn't moved up a lot and you see this
downward converging of the different
futures price this is what people
normally refer to when they say a market
is in contango when you see the delivery
price of a certain futures contract
converge downward to the actual spot
price all of these are converging
downward over time so it's something
that you would have to observe over time
not something that you would
traditionally just be able to look at a
futures curve but in general when you
have this you normally see that the
futures delivery prices are higher the
further out you go so you have this
upward sloping futures curve so the
simplest kind of analysis when people
say something is incontango they'll just
look at an upward sloping futures curve
or a normal curve and they'll say this
is also in tango incontango but this
isn't this isn't exactly right it's
really these movements over time